النحل في ورطة يموتون
بمعدلات تنذر بالخطر بسبب التدخل البشري
ولكن كوكبنا يحتاجهم
هذا الرجل يستخدم البيانات من
أصوات النحل للمساعدة في زيادة الوعي وهو
يفعل ذلك باستخدام الموسيقى الإلكترونية التجريبية
في حياتي نصف عدد
النحل  اختفى
، أريد أن ألفت الانتباه إلى
محنة النحل من خلال صوتهم ، أستخدم
اسم Bo knee كاسم مستعار ، إنه ليس
اسمي الحقيقي ،
مرحبًا بكم في منزل النحل الخاص بي ، لقد بدأت في
تسجيل النحل في خليتي منذ حوالي 20
عامًا ، ودائمًا ما أرتدي هذا خمر
بدلة النحل لأنني أريد أن
يركز الناس فقط على موسيقاي ، كل
موسيقاي التي تدور حول أصوات النحل ،
إنه صوت النحل الفعلي داخل
خلايا النحل الذي أخذته ومعالجته
إلى أصوات جديدة وهو أيضًا
صوت العسل حيث  تمرير
تيار كهربائي عبر نحلة العسل ، تستخدم يوني
معدات منزلية الصنع لاستخراج البيانات من
الأصوات والترددات المختلفة للملكة.
والطائرات بدون طيار هي صوت ذو طبقة صوت منخفضة
يمكنني استخراج عينات من التسجيلات
ووضعها على جهاز المزج الخاص بي
ثم تشغيلها مباشرة أثناء قيامي
بالسفر حول العالم ، ودعوتهم إلى
المهرجانات الموسيقية التي
تهتم بالبيئة كما يأمل أن  سيتأثر عدد كافٍ من
الناس بموسيقاه
للنظر في تأثيرها على مجموعات النحل
، وأعتقد أن أصوات النحل ترتبط
بالناس ، إنها عاطفية جدًا ، لذلك اعتقدت أنه
إذا كان الناس يهتمون بالنحل من خلال
صوتهم والجانب التكنولوجي
والتعليم الذي سيصبحون كذلك
مهتم
بالجانب البيئي وكذلك بإنقاذ النحل
[موسيقى]